oui à plus de made in Europe produire en
Europe c'est être moins dépendant de
l'extérieur c'est bon pour nos emplois
et c'est aussi bon pour l'environnement
et produire en Europe c'est
particulièrement important pour les
secteurs de l'énergie et de la
transition énergétique c'est pourquoi la
Commission européenne a proposé cette
semaine le plan industriel pour le pacte
vert européen cela soit des panneaux
solaires ou des batteries ce plan doit
faciliter leur production en Europe
Eva notamment faciliter les formalités
administratives pour nos entreprises on
reproche parfois à l'Union européenne de
proposer trop de règles ici nous allons
faire mentir cette idée reçue et
simplifier
dans le cadre de ce plan un fonds
européen de souveraineté va être mis en
place ce qui était une demande de notre
groupe réunion Europe
l'idée tout simplement mieux financer
les secteurs stratégiques comme la
défense la santé ou l'énergie
ce fond sera une grande avancée nous
permettant d'investir en européen dans
des secteurs clés
il pourrait par exemple servir à
produire plus de paracétamol en Europe
alors que nous produisons quasiment plus
ou alors construire davantage
d'éoliennes que nous souhaitons
installer dans l'océan vous le voyez
nous avons sont sur le soutien à
l'industrie verte et soit ils assurer
que je continuerai à défendre au nom du
modèle et de réunion Europe notre
stratégie d'autonomie et toujours plus
de made in Europe